[Musica]
fin dalla preistoria
noi come esseri umani abbiamo cercato di
superare i nostri limiti
estendendo le nostre capacità e lo
abbiamo fatto con lo sviluppo
tecnologico per estendere la velocità
con cui ci muoviamo abbiamo inventato
l'automobile per estendere il nostro
tempo abbiamo inventato agli
elettrodomestici
provate a pensare quanto tempo ci fanno
risparmiare lavatrice lavastoviglie
tempo che possiamo dedicare a fare
dell'altro e per estendere le nostre
abilità mentali diminuire gli errori che
facciamo facile abbiamo inventato il
personal computer e per estendere le
nostre conoscenze in tutto il mondo
generare condividere dati abbiamo
inventato internet lo sviluppo
tecnologico ha interessato nel corso
degli anni un po tutti gli aspetti della
nostra vita come viaggiamo a come
comunichiamo ma riguarda soprattutto il
futuro del lavoro in particolare il
futuro il futuro del lavoro in fabbrica
già dal 1900 1960 sono stati introdotti
i primi robot nera di nina di
assemblaggio
l'obiettivo era quello di facilitare le
mansioni degli operai e diminuire gli
errori aumentando anche la sicurezza di
che cosa sono ci sono subito accorti gli
operai
beh primo il robot erano forti
instancabili e diminuivano gli errori
secondo i robot erano molto stupidi
senza un sistema di sensori che li di
una conoscenza completa per l'ambiente
in cui stanno un robot non può vedere e
quindi se qualcosa se il più piccolo
parametro dell'ambiente in cui opera
cambia il robot 1 riuscirà a portare a
termine il proprio compito
nel prossimo video vedremo un sistema
robotico che deve dare il biberon a un
bambino
il biberon si trovasse un tavolo che
deve il robot per spostarlo dal tavolo
al bambino quello che rob non sa e dove
si trova precisamente non riesce quindi
a riconoscerne la presenza vediamo cosa
succede
diciamo che non era forse quello che si
aspettavano
se qualcuno interessato magari poi ne
parliamo sviluppiamo qualcosa c'è un
limite da superare per superare questo
limite
dobbiamo prendere il meglio di due mondi
quello umano e quello robotico il robot
è preciso
instancabile forte umano e creativo e
intuitivo per superare questo limite
dobbiamo collaborare
dobbiamo collaborare con le macchine e
loro con noi nel campo dell ice della
ricerca questo si chiama robotica
collaborativa e vogliamo veramente
estendere la capacità dei robot che
finora abbiamo solo provato ad estendere
perché finora abbiamo utilizzato delle
protesi
abbiamo utilizzato degli strumenti come
l'automobile o il pc o appunto staccando
delle protesi la robotica collaborativa
vuole andare oltre
utilizzando la simbiosi tra uomo e robot
creando una simbiosi molto forte e
questa collaborazione
grazie a questa collaborazione l'uomo
può estendere quello che da solo non
riesce a fare e allo stesso tempo il
robot può estendere da solo poi
estendere quello che da solo non riesce
a fare grazie a questa collaborazione
l'uomo può ritornare ad essere creativo
impiegando veramente più tempo a fare
quello che gli piace quello che lo
valorizza di più lasciando fare robot
attività più pesanti e ripetitive
in questo video vediamo come una
collaborazione di questo tipo può venire
in fabbrica
da una parte c'è l'uomo che è occupato a
fare attività po più difficili per un
robot come ad esempio l'inserimento di
uno spinotto dall'altra c'è il robot che
gli dà una mano che per esempio per leva
e compongo componente e lo mette al di
sopra del prodotto finito e questa
collaborazione è sempre più utilizzata
in industria soprattutto in quella
manifatturiera ma collaborare con noi
umani non essere estremamente
imprevedibili e molto difficile
insegnare a un robot a collaborare con
noi è una sfida
se ci pensiamo anche la collaborazione
tra umani non è del tutto semplice ogni
giorno a casa al lavoro a scuola
dobbiamo collaborare per raggiungere
determinati obiettivi
per esempio per assemblare una finestra
dobbiamo essere almeno in due
e bisogna collaborare e coordinarsi e
come ci si coordinano beh tramite le
parole ma non solo anche tramite il
contatto visivo contatto visivo
effettivamente un buon metodo per
comunicare intenzioni istruzioni sé ma
anche alla collaborazione verbale e non
verbale come riusciremo a raggiungere il
risultato voluto
un po come fanno stanlio e ollio
sappiamo che c'è un limite da superare
sappiamo che collaborare che la
collaborazione uomo uomo estremamente
difficile immaginate la collaborazione
uomo robot come può un robot
interpretare correttamente le nostre
espressioni facciali come disse un robot
a calarsi nei panni dell'operaio per
capirne punti di vista pensieri emozioni
intenzioni un robot deve solo imparare a
gestire il proprio spazio
fisico ma anche lo spazio emotivo
dell'uomo per garantire questa
collaborazione una collabora
collaborazione più efficace di quindi
una forma di comunicazione che è
intangibile silenziosa ma allo stesso
tempo profonda e potente che non ha
bisogno delle parole ma si serve del
linguaggio del corpo
l'empatia in futuro la collaborazione
tra uomo e robot e macchina potrà essere
favorita tramite l'introduzione di un
intelligenza emotiva all'interno del
robot e questo è importante perché è
stato dimostrato che il robot che l'uomo
collabora meglio se riceve delle
risposte empatiche dal robot e allo
stesso tempo i robot collabora meglio se
riesce a capirne tutte le risposte
empatiche questo sono io e mi occupo di
ricerca applicata
quindi cerco di prendere la ricerca di
base sviluppata all'università e prova
applicarla ad un caso industriale reale
recentemente è stata sviluppata questa
teoria del rapporto empatico tra uomo e
mo però bot
e noi questo lo vorremmo applicare ad un
caso industriale e come si fa
abbiamo già fatto una ricerca su campi
su settori non industriali come ad
esempio il settore dei servizi in
particolare per assistenza domestica
ora stiamo definendo i prossimi passi
stiamo cercando partner di progetto
questa è una strada io ci credo
veramente
credo che sia una strada cerco di
percorrere ogni giorno ma sono sicuro di
una cosa che la collaborazione uomo uomo
anche in sé la più difficile
come abbiamo visto sarà sempre la più
importante perché ci ricorda di cosa
siamo fatti di relazioni ed emozioni
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]